- Live, damn it, live!
(gasps)
- Oh my god!
You just saved my life!
How can I ever thank you?
- Just don't wait to live your life.
Go do it.
Now!
Oh hi! I'm Megan.
And recently, I completed some stuff
off my bucket list.
And now I just want to give other people
the opportunity to do the same thing.
This week, we're gonna hang
out with Jazzmyne Robbins.
She's a video producer here at Buzz Feed,
and one of the most confident,
bold people, that I know.
So, if you had to do three
things off of your bucket list,
What would they be?
- One, do a completely naked photo shoot.
I've never done that before
and I really think it
would be pushing myself.
I want to be tattooed by a woman,
because I have so many
empowerment tattoos,
but none of them have been by women.
I also want to inspire
people, like, face to face
to do something off their bucket list.
- I mean, I think we can make that happen,
if you're free this week.
- I think I can make some time.
- Okay great, let's do it!
(lively music)
(camera clicking sound)
Jazz, why is this on your bucket list?
- I'm always someone who's like,
be yourself, be you, no matter what.
You know, and I think I show that often.
But I've never really pushed
myself to the extreme.
(upbeat music)
I want to look fashionable,
relaxed, and still myself.
I want it to be quirky.
I want it to be a little, like, rough.
Like, my body is not like the
ideal body for other people,
but it's the ideal for me.
(upbeat music)
So when I go to photo shoots,
I'm used to putting my body in
a way that looks flattering.
In this, I don't necessarily
want it to look flattering.
I just want it to look
like comfortable and me.
Some poses aren't gonna
look the most flattering,
but they're gonna look the most real.
And that's what I wanna protract.
(upbeat music)
I just got the photos.
I'm a little scared.
Jazz nude.
It's called Jazz Nude.
Oh!
I love this picture of
me sitting in this chair,
butt ass naked.
I really like the ones
with nothing on them.
This is just me.
Raw.
The pictures with the beret and the fur,
fire.
This is truly like what I wanted to do.
I'm excited.
- It's tattoo time!
So Jazz doesn't know that
I sent ahead a picture
from her photo shoot, to
the tattoo artist, Zoey.
And Zoey has drawn up a tattoo for Jazz,
with that nude photo as inspiration.
And hopefully she likes it,
because it's going on her body forever.
Why is this on your bucket list?
- I have so many tattoos,
that have to do with
being a powerful woman,
and just being empowered in general.
There's always been just
a little missing link,
that none of my female empowerment tattoos
have been from a woman.
So like having a boss ass woman,
give me a boss ass tattoo.
It would just be awesome.
- Do you have any idea
what you're gonna get?
- I have no idea at all.
- I have an idea.
Jazz, Zoey. Zoey, Jazz.
- Hi! Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- I sent ahead a picture from
your nude photo shoot to Zoey.
Are you ready to see it?
- I'm kinda freaking out,
and I'm kinda sweating but sure.
- It's gonna be great.
Can we see it?
- Oh!
I love her.
I truly love this.
I like the thickness.
It's an empowering-like stance.
- Yey!
Let's put it on you forever.
- Yeah.
(upbeat music)
- Ready?
- Yeah.
- Are you ready?
(tattoo gun buzzing)
- Oh! That's the noise.
(techno music)
Usually, my mom comes and holds my hand.
That's it?
- That's it.
- I love it.
This is exactly what I wanted.
It's clean.
It's simple.
But it reminds me a message
of loving and appreciating
every part of yourself.
And this is exactly what I
wanted to go along with this arm.
- So today we're hitting
the streets of Hollywood,
so Jazz can ask other people,
What's on their bucket list?
So Jazz, why is his the final
thing on your bucket list?
- Because of this, I've
become really inspired.
And I feel like, me,
meeting people face to face
and inspiring them to do
something on their bucket list,
will be awesome.
Alright, I'm out here on the corner.
And I'm realizing how much
I hate approaching people.
Yeah, you wanna come be in a vid?
Yeah, I really hate approaching people.
(laughs)
(light instrumental music)
I'm gonna cry.
I love that.
(lively music)
Hi, what's your name?
- Joe.
- What do you want to do before you die?
- I wanna make people laugh.
- Oh.
Go ahead and write it down.
(lively music)
- To create a feature length film.
- Oh okay, go ahead and write
it down wherever you can.
(lively music)
(clapping)
A lot of people put some really
big picture goals on here.
- [Jazz] It was good.
I feel good about this.
- [Megan] Yey! Let's go eat lunch.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- I'm fucking starving.
(lively music)
Honestly, this whole process has like,
made me think of future stuff more.
There's so much I wanna do.
So yeah, I think I'm gonna
like, keep on pushing
for, like, my goals and my dreams.
It was just like, a whole
new point of empowerment
for myself.
Who's next?
- I'm not sure.
Who is next?
Let us know below in the comments.
Wanna go get some ice cream?
- I want sushi.
- That's so different.
(laughs)
We can get sushi.
Let's go.
(lively music)